es wurde sich zahlreich gewünscht in den
kommentaren unter meinen videos und
besonders ein spiel spaß da besonders
heraus was ihr unbedingt mal wieder
sehen wollte und dabei handelt es sich
um reynolds schon ziemlich krass oder
betrete das hinterzimmer und mache dich
auf die flucht also wir sind dieser
kleine volltrottel hier und müssen wir
aus dieser zelle ausbrechen von dem ich
jetzt einfach mal den schlüssel uns
drauf
oder den anderen
[Musik]
ja das war klar dass das alles ja nicht
klappt haben wir auf das schloss gegen
die draufklicken nee das geht auch nicht
auf die lampe können wir auch nicht
drauf klicken können wir ihnen ziehen
die schlüssel zu hab ich sie mal
durchgespielt
im nächsten rätsel müssen wir jetzt die
wache erschrecken ich nehme einfach mal
die maus das klappt nicht uns selber
kaputt ich kann mir das nicht irgendwie
auf die wache draufklicken nie irgendwas
nicht nebenberuflich wasserfall kleiner
jetzt müssen wir die wache gehen lassen
hier oben ist
[Musik]
könnte ich mein ich bin michael gefehlt
der scherz besiege die wachen okay jetzt
müssen wir sie besiegen - 4
wir können also
wir können theoretisch sie die ganze
zeit einfach hier attackieren und dann
ist irgendwann das okay das ist jetzt
nämlich langweilig eine stunde später
zwei stunden später dass wir das ding
irgendwie schütteln 20.300 87 stunden
später bestechung
sonst ist das hier also tür ist
verschlossen wie komme ich heraus okay
hier vorne steht ein coach ich glaube
also auf die df einfach drüber floss
sprengt das geht nicht hier auf den
coach was müssen sie mit rekorden machen
drei tonnen kohle gehirn 900 207 ok 90
02 07
[Musik]
ich verstehe
meine güte die tür war wieder falsch
wie die tür ist wieder verschloss er
macht sich wieder kleiner dicker also
kleiner machen können wir ihn auf jeden
fall nicht wir können auf das 2
oh mann ich bin schreibt gemerkt
[Musik]
ich hab gedacht ist die lärche dein
gedächtnis ist echt gut danke danke der
schere stein papier du musst gewinnen
okay ich mache ich ja verloren die
sammeln gegen den computer schere stein
papier gewinnen
nachdenken schiebe die gesundheit der
wache direkt von rechts nach links auf
null deger das sind halt keine tipps
sind einfach die lösungen
so mega praktisch fix mit luca gestaltet
jetzt besser wenn ich irgendwann mal
überfallen werden sollte oder wenn euch
ein mörder umbringen wird oder sowas ist
ganz einfach sein gesundheits balken und
schiebt den rüberschieben steigen und in
den chinesischen herstellern aufstocker
dann öffne die zimmertür so ich ich
ich kann nicht so richtig machen den
kopf drehen geht auch nicht
[Musik]
finde schlüssel ist sehen wir das
nächste ding ich hab keine ahnung warum
da irgend so eine pause
das ist jetzt nicht wahr das heißt nicht
dass die lösung auch erneut eingesperrt
dass der blöden das licht ist
mittlerweile auch aus ich kann nur
es ist nachts und dementsprechend
schläft die wache und wir dürfen sie
nicht aufwecken also mach mal ganz
langsam
[Musik]
hier geht alles supi bei dir kinder von
jahren
der schlüssel ist erneut verschwunden
rose wieder hier hinter irgendwo
nächster nicht hier bei der sache
ordentlich
[Musik]
beharre der sieg liegt vor uns ja
irgendwie sind wir aber immer noch in
der las die wache von hier weggehen okay
wir müssen wahrscheinlich wieder einen
code eingeben
wir haben verschiedene sachen drin und
beruf ist einfach mal alles
[Musik]
so einfach da stecke dein handy damit
die wachen lässt sich finden
ich gucke nicht auf den spielen drauf
wie soll ich mein handy
ich muss es ist nicht das wieder denke
es ist ein kopfhörer ja genauso wie die
neuen apple kopfhörer die einfache 600
euro kosten
so keine ahnung man damit in die zukunft
hören kann flüchtete aus dem raum kann
ich mich nehmen kann ich nicht kann ich
irgendwie hier hoch klettern
was jetzt sie mitmachen ein paar
sekunden später
ach so ach das kann ich auch wegnehmen
ok oh mein gott die schulden schluss
startete aber wie oft verlieren ihre
schlüssel
ja das ist des rätsels lösung mülltonnen
größer oder kleiner ziehen funktioniert
ebenfalls nicht ich kann ich kann ich es
ist schon ein gutes angebot hier gerade
ich war da nicht drauf habe dreimal
hintereinander auf den mülleimer du
findest alle mülleimer nacheinander ok
als wert 3 1 238 so und jetzt irgendwo
da drin ist was ich auch selbst drauf
kommen können vorletztes rätsel kommt
schon lasst die wachen gehen und du bist
fast schon draußen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der ultimative level heißt es sich das
level findet den schlüssel und stimme
aus dem zimmer also wir haben ein
goldfischglas wahrscheinlich muss die
katze zum so
was gegessen dann nehmen wir ja
hmm
jetzt sei goldfisch
neu gestartet der goldfisch lebt wieder
das heißt wir könnten den goldfisch
theoretisch auch hier auf uns packen
hier in den kreisligen was für ein kreis
dk wenn wir hier irgendwas verschieben
das tat auch nicht irgendwas hierum
drehen schütteln dann muss der fisch
glaube ich gegessen werden das ist
unglaublich folge hinterrücks und das
ist nicht ein krimi sondern eigentlich
ist das eine richtige politische
tragödie schecks halt wirklich nicht ich
klicke hier alles mögliche irgendwie an
und es passiert nichts
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind frei